we get the ping-pong a lot of light
comedy and bad words and naughty
business yes up in the animation world
you know you don't have to put makeup on
no sweat pants all day long I need a
crew no you need a shower eight hours of
that I don't have to spend in hair
makeup Kaley executive produces and
stars as Harley Quinn Lake is her BFF
poison ivy but beware this cartoon is
not for the kids
how dirty doesn't really get dirty
Harley it's me when I read the script
but were you just like yes this is gonna
be the start of something huge this is a
departure for you especially from you
know a network show things are a little
more family-friendly who came up with
that you did that's right I did
are you sure this would be a departure
for anyone yeah well a psychotic yeah
really sick you way more like you right
exactly
most people know that behind the scenes
buy me a shoot together we don't pray
we're together we don't even get to hang
out this is we just met today I don't
even know this woman yeah another set
secret there was a limit on the amount
of bad words they could use per episode
and you really make use of those oh yeah
there's often a fight yeah I'm a girl
gets it you're like it's the little leg
take the left again will you use any of
this interview this will not air they
kept our sensor button busy and I loved
it Harley Quinn premieres this Friday
[Music]